this there's no organization or plan
today
um everybody gets to participate at the
level they wish
and
um I came with no real agenda I could uh
talk about Carl for quite a while but I
don't see a need for it most of the
people here know him by reputation if
not by in person
he was a common uh fixture at e380
and so I think that what we should do is
just talk a little bit about
Carl and his uh his contributions what
it is that he he actually did and if
there are students in our audience which
there should be
um if you have questions about Carl and
what his contributions work ask him of
this group because these people know
okay
well I came with a question
but I don't know if I should start it
off you're the one who started off on
you Carl has this very simple free-line
proof that purportedly
um contradicted one of girdle's
serums
the one about
um
mathematics not being able to prove
its consistency
and this proof
proved mathematics consistency
and I wonder if anybody
has any I had any
ideas about that what they think about
it uh do they believe it
or anything
hold on
do they believe it do if they do do what
is the significance of it
or
uh you know how to understand it okay
the comment I was making is that you can
prove anything if you have the right
assumptions
so what is the proof
I'm afraid somebody's gonna ask me that
it's it's
uh I always get it every time I hear it
uh but it's uh it's I don't know Dennis
do you know it by heart no I don't
know it's something like this but I'm
afraid I might make a mistake it's
something like uh it's proof by
contradiction
so if you want to prove that mathematics
uh proves its own consistency then you
assume that it doesn't prove its own
consistency and then you at the end and
then you have another line and I forget
what that is at the end you have p and
not P which is false which means
the premise is proved it goes something
like that but I might I'm sure I'm
leaving things out and I'm not a
logician but it's in the uh his book The
inconsistency robustness book
well I to paraphrase uh John McCarthy
I'm in no position to call his bluff
but I did I did uh uh go to a seminar
where he talked about that kind of thing
and I remember arguing against uh some
things he did and he argued back and I
wasn't convinced by his argument but now
I don't remember what the uh what the
details were but I don't remember anyone
ever uh everything oh I understand it
and he's right
yes I I he explained it several times in
the fryan sessions
um his his the point I took was that
um the logic system has to accept PN not
p and if it does then you can prove that
mathematics is consistent and so he was
saying that that girdles uh premises
were incomplete
now that's as much understanding as I
have of it
I'm thinking I am reminded of John
rushby's proofs of the existence of God
or or the non-existence of God and you
can prove anything if you if you set it
up right
uh he also uh used or he he also proved
in addition to that that
um
the Russell's the uh
Russell's Paradox uh sentence the uh I
am not approved for whatever the
sentence is the colonel used uh could
not be should not be allowed
the self-referential the
self-referential sentence uh cannot be
allowed because it's jumps levels
basically right he was he was always I
think he as I recall he connected it to
second order Logistics
is not sufficient
right something like that
so does anybody believe the proof
he never convinced me but he was so much
smarter I really couldn't argue with him
foreign
okay
and I think
I think he convinced me that he was onto
something but I think that so much of
mathematics depends upon uh things that
he was perfectly willing to toss out on
the um
out of the um
a hamper
um maybe we need to rethink things on
refined definitions a little bit before
we go
uh throwing out the baby with the bath
water
I think he didn't accept tarsky and
semantics so uh what he meant by
validity might be different from what
logicians would take to be
yeah
Carl had a habit of using terminology to
mean something other than what everybody
else thought it meant
[Laughter]
and maybe everybody else didn't have a
consistent view of what it meant that's
probably true too
the nice part about Carl attending the
Friday meeting was we had two hours when
we were meeting physically of in the
room uh being able to question him in
detail and push him on the details so we
may have gotten more coherent
explanation than many I don't know that
any of us fully understood him on many
of these points but we did have the
opportunity
we tried out quite a few new ideas on us
and I thought that was uh well was
interesting I found myself arguing with
him on various uh issues
but it was usually definitional because
his definitions were were a little bit
awkwardly different from what everybody
else thought was uh the way it was done
and I keep coming back to my earlier
remark you can always prove almost
anything if you have the right set of
assumptions
which may be false well I think in the
book he argues how his assumptions are
all pretty standard
because I looked it up this morning
I mean I don't know that they are but he
states that you know I make this
assumption and that's pretty you know
and he has some references and and it's
pretty well understood that this is it
and it is this assumption this is kind
of standard and that's standard so he
does make he does try to make a case
that the definitions and assumptions
he's using are are kind of standard and
and uh wide widely uh used
to some extent I thought he lived within
his own virtual logical reality
so he he did Bend things a little bit
here and there
he had his own Distortion field yeah
well most of us live in our own virtual
realities that's not a surprise yeah
and sometimes we do it subconsciously
without knowing that we're doing it
mission aborted but I think the
important thing was uh Carl was trying
to
solve deep problems
and he wasn't afraid of criticism yeah
people didn't understand him he didn't
get angry he just explained more now the
explanation may not have been any better
than the original one but he kept trying
he seem to have infinite patience with
people who didn't get what he was
talking about
and and even people with no credentials
like me
um
uh you know I I have no training in
computer science my background I have a
PhD in astronomy I I tell people I
learned computer science the way I
learned about sex on the street corner
from my friends and
Carl Carl was always very patient with
me and uh he was always trying to fill
in the gaps in my knowledge so that I
could understand it better he definitely
was not a snob you know if I said
something stupid he didn't just walk
away from me he
explained why I was wrong and then
continued with his
um incomprehensible descriptions yeah
where did you where were you um in
contact with him at the fryer meeting so
here I am okay after several several
years I don't know three or four years
at least he was a regular attendee
God he always had a paper that he was
about to give and he wanted to do a dry
run on it right Martin gang often did
that and we always told him his slides
had too many colors and too many fonts
you know I always told him that I told
him that he made everything too bright
and too sharp and and and you know it
was it was distracting yes you can
simplify it and I told him over and over
and over again and he didn't take it
into account he he was like incapable of
getting rid of all these blaring colors
and fonts and
squiggles and squaggles he often asked
me to review his slides and uh I I am
very
careful about the flow the story I'm
telling a talk is a story and it has to
flow and he did take my suggestions on
improving the flow on several of his
talks so I felt like I contributed
something
he always gave me he gave me his slides
too to review and uh and sometimes he
would tone down the fonts and the colors
but then in the next iteration they
would be back I never I never succeeded
on fonts and colors but I did get him to
do some reorganization so he was telling
the story more clearly I thought he had
a habit of I think there was specific
feedback he was seeking on particular
aspects of things and he just sort of
filtered out anything that wasn't that
um and he was very good at not listening
to you and I think that was part of uh
part of what led him focus on me sort of
deep deep abstraction
just
not listening and making you think he is
listening well no no you you could it
was like I I had lots of wonderful
arguments with him
um both at fry him and he he when I was
working at PayPal he he somehow
developed the habit of inviting himself
over for lunch you know every week or
two and uh and we and then I'd end up
spending the afternoon arguing
impact or something with him and and it
was like if if the thing that you were
focusing on was the thing that he was
focusing on then you could have these
amazingly fruitful conversations and if
the thing that he was focusing on was
something and you were
seeing some other thing off to the side
he would just be like he just wouldn't
hear you
Focus
I remember when talking gave where I uh
asked a question about one of the axioms
I thought it was uh
different from one of his earlier axioms
and he changed it on the side with that
and I was I wasn't actually saying it
was wrong just saying it could have
didn't I would ask asking why why it was
the way but he just he just changed it
without worrying about whether this what
this did to the rest of his system he
just uh was uh
didn't care about consistency Richmond
he didn't mind he didn't mind uh
inconsistency
well he he had this um way of looking at
long-standing problems in a completely
different way there's a um a system
where you're going to have several
communicating components
um in this particular model called
object capabilities and when they're
distributed there's a a pretty standard
way that's being been reinvented several
times for getting controlling the way
they talk to each other
and Carl came up with something that was
completely different
and it took us forever I think I was one
of the few people at Ryan who finally
figured out what it was where he was he
was calling a type an actor
and uh uh and you know that is such a
strange phrase
that threw a lot of people off and it
took me months going back and forth with
him and I did feed my explanation back
to him and he said yes that's it I'm not
convinced I was right yet but maybe he
was just trying to make me feel better
but I think that was characteristic of
his career well to be fair didn't he
introduce the term actor before uh yeah
absolutely stuff came along yeah
for him everything was an actor or
everything could be
whittled down to being an actor like a
plus sign or something who was an actor
who is an actor right and I actually I
actually use that in a in a project
um in small talk two as an object so in
Carl's turn that's an actor and I needed
complex arithmetic ah and I figured out
how to send the message I to a number
oh nice yes that was it was a small talk
pun I thought that's very nice yeah and
so the two was an actor so I could send
it a message
um Paul you got your hand up
so uh changing the subject slightly who
all remembers uh Carl's belt pack
particularly in the 80s
sure yeah that Carl I think qualifies as
the original EDC guy so for the
uninitiated EDC is everyday carry and
the very first time I met Carl it was at
some some nerd Soiree in Monterey Bay
and he proudly showed I think it might
have even been a uh an assilimar vet he
proudly showed me his belt pack that
included 120 feet of piano wire in case
he needed to Evac out of the third story
of a building it wasn't clear to me
whether he actually had a descending
device or if he was going to wear gloves
but I remember being much taken by you
know the the the forethought and and
shared nerdy practicality of Carl it
wasn't just bits he was he was going to
make himself safe in a world of atoms
too we also carried a suitcase around
with him uh on on Wheels
I guess the Computing equipment got to
be heavier and heavier
so what was in it Peter do you remember
oh sometimes he opened it up and pulled
out papers and sometimes it was a
computer sometimes it was other things
lunch I had this huge old uh MacBook Pro
and I think it was a 17 inch screen it
must have weighed it looked like you
know the old uh early uh Portables that
you know the luggables with the handle
on it was that big
um so he wasn't going to be carrying
that very far
but yeah I had tons of papers in there
it's always nice to have a big screen
yes you gotta have that big screen he
wasn't going to replace that machine
he wasn't good at garbage collection
now in in the early days at MIT
he always had a key ring with must have
been 20 or 30 keys on it did he continue
with that through it absolutely always
had this gigantic key ring I think most
of those keys you didn't know what they
were anymore and they didn't work yeah
but but uh he was probably afraid to
throw any of them out yeah just in case
right exactly but
for uh uh Bullhead master keys
keys so he figured you know anybody that
had a lot of keys was an important
person
that was before master keys now the
important person that has only one key
well I get MIT that opens all the doors
[Music]
well I remember Paul I remember Carl
when he uh got his first uh Newton
and was running around showing how
paragraph converted perfectly ordinary
text into haiku
and it was it was quite amazing uh the
Newton of course was a much nicer
machine than we'd all admit today but it
was
yeah I remember he told me he showed me
his dreams that someday you're going to
have one of these in your future you
know that uh basically everyone was
going to be have carrying around uh
a computer and of course he was right
but I didn't take it very seriously he's
right I got four of them in my basement
including
um uh one of the Siemens Newton desk
phones that had little you know
telephone handle and a docking station
and stuff so yeah as usual he predicted
it
he did love those gadgets I kept running
into him at the Samsung developer
conference at Moscone where he seemed
very interested in the ties operating
system which was Samsung's proprietary
version of Linux as I recall and he was
full of derision for the way that system
you know details of some Linux version
you know I think of linux's as being
roughly similar to each other but he
seemed
uh Revel in the fine points of that
specific thing I think he may have been
going because there were these giveaways
you know you if you registered as a
faculty they would give you uh like a
watch or something like that and he
liked the gadgets
so in his last few years Carl was uh
continually talking about the hololens
the Microsoft power lens and how we'd
all be wearing these smart glasses and
um how that would be everything and uh
you know we we didn't believe him but
maybe it's like we didn't believe him
about the Newton and in a few more years
we'll all be wearing hololens well the
hololens isn't going to catch on until
they uh sell it you know with the
package including some white surgical
tape so people can tape the uh Bridge
[Laughter]
um
does anybody have memories of him as an
undergrad at MIT did he do the steam
tunnel thing
tell us about the steam tunnel thing uh
I I didn't I I wasn't smart enough to go
to MIT
I went to uh uh College down the road
aways in Cambridge uh and and we we had
our version of steam tunnels and there
were basically at Harvard there were
only uh two things that would get you
expelled from Harvard one was aggravated
assault or murder and the other was
getting caught in the Harvard steam
tunnels and we were all in awe of the
MIT undergrads because they had clearly
done a much better job of mapping all
the hidden steam tunnels and passages
under the university than we had
and he just struck me with his little
everyday carry kid I figured he must
have been in the thick of that
no I meant Pearl I think his last year's
graduate student that was my first year
in the AI lab okay so I didn't know him
as an undergrad
well I I have a question for you did
Carl have the same laugh back then that
he did oh yes
I can't do it justice
he did have that very distinctive laugh
very much
I think there should be a panel uh where
all all the speakers have unusual laughs
only that only we shouldn't tell them
why they were invited to be on this like
the python Department of funny walks
uh yeah the same sort of thing for but
for laughs
you know I was I
I've been giving some thought to what I
could say about coral under this these
circumstances because
You Know Carl and I were intellectually
very opposed to each other but I
something that I can say
appreciatively is although Carl and I
disagreed on almost any technical point
you could imagine
unlike some of the other people in the
AI lab
at the time he never made any attempt to
obstruct me getting my degrees
yeah I don't think
um Carl took criticism of his work
as personally as many as as many have I
know
um he uh he told us Tales of uh uh what
went on in MIT with actors versus scheme
versus uh uh several of the other
proposals but uh
um he never struck me as being bitter
about the disagreements
oh that's but he never forgot them
right that's the way he would he would
hand me papers and say you know that I
was supposed to criticize everything I
could find
that was my job for a while
anyway go ahead and I interrupt you I
was gonna say I was when I was an MIT
working my bachelor's thesis in 1978 so
I'd have to work the evening shift to
get a terminal
and Carl would just wander in
at some point and start telling me
something that was interesting
and we had a great talk I don't know why
he picked me out
you know I mean I think he was kind of
going down the hall to see who was there
uh and I also remember this fight I
remember yeah I remember you know he and
Jerry had opposing viewpoints
but Jerry was the one who was very very
angry and Carl
managed to avoid that which is what uh
somebody else just said that he didn't
he didn't
he didn't he didn't feel like he had to
correct something right away that it was
wrong and you had to tell everybody
which I appreciated
it was laconic but I might say in that
regard
so I've always had a question why why
did Carl leave MIT
I think you're probably
in the best position to answer that
it's complicated
yes
oh come on
it's not being recorded
it is being recorded it is being
recorded So you want to be careful and
we have a reporter here too
it's always an ex-reporter where where's
the reporter identified
retired
oh it's clear Carl wanted someplace
sunnier
ah let's just say actually he's dead if
you can believe check gbt
foreign
I would have not been surprised at that
McCarthy did as well and he came out to
Stanford in the 60s
a power that beat made that made life
difficult for him
huh well it was our game
but then you know I always wanted him to
move to California because I had moved
from California to live with him in
Boston because I met him out here
uh but then when he finally I quoted got
divorced from MIT
he overshot and went to Hawaii for a
couple years
really
yeah who is who is he working with in
Hawaii oh he was trying to interest the
University of Hawaii to do some of his
work but he could never get any traction
with that I don't think there was
anybody there I I remember friends and
the chairman of the department who was
one of the great early error correcting
what Peterson West Peterson I I gave a
ACM lecture out there to spend a week
out there I had a wonderful time Peter
hadn't had Franco moved to Sri by the
time Carl left MIT
uh sorry what was that question hadn't
Frank quo move to Sri
music Bill Labs with me oh and then he
went to Hawaii
um with Norm Abramson and and all of
that uh uh uh the the network stuff that
they developed
for a bunch of years
yeah but I think I think he was at SRI
when when
that was much later we're all left MIT
yeah that I I think he was uh no I think
he'd already been in Hawaii
right but I'm saying I don't think Carl
would have moved to Hawaii to work with
Frank because Frank was already gone
yeah but I don't think I think whether
he was or not I don't think he would
have gone to work with Frank
anyway he became enamored with MIT
because he had had a year sabbatical in
Japan somebody in Japan invited him to
um
to some yeah to some Institute to be
there for a year and uh
and going back and forth between Japan
and Boston he would spend some time in
Hawaii
so then he decided once he left MIT that
he wanted to go to Hawaii because they
had warm water there even though I
wanted I wanted him to move to
California
he did windsurfing and snorkeling and
various things
so he bought a house that ended up being
too expensive and he fixed it up and
sold it
foreign
so I want to encourage to join in here
you must know all sorts of stories but
you're on mute
so I'll unmute
um not stories but I do have some
questions
um I would routinely run into Carl
around Stanford over a number of years
and he would always tell me stories that
were vaguely Sinister that involved
National Security things and the Chinese
and the FBI and I never quite got to the
bottom of anything they were always
incredibly entertaining and you know as
a reporter it was uh you know it was
like
um it was catnip but I never got
anywhere with any of it and it left me
wondering about his relationship to
National Security if there was anything
at all well you know he you spent a lot
of time telling stories about what
seemed to be inside National Security
stories uh some of them were I
discovered later were public and and
others were less so uh he may have some
friends in there that were tipping him
off on something or other but he loved
he loved that kind of juicy story to
tell
like no one else on this call
I don't have any funny funny
I also thought that he was a bit
paranoid about such things
oh very much but then again I might be
naive no no no that's exactly right I
mean he really was uh uh felt threatened
by by the NSA and the uh the FBI and and
others institutions Department of
Justice
maybe that goes along with the piano
wire yeah well that goes along with the
early in the 60s being anti-war
anti-vietnam and protesting yeah but the
last National Security thing I remember
him talking about were these back doors
on all our devices of course computers
and he seemed to believe that it could
be done securely and we kept trying to
talk him out of it but I don't think we
ever succeeded
the paranoia I never got traction on
that argument the the standard story I
tell is that if you can't trust the
hardware you can't trust the software
and if you can't trust a software you
can't trust the apps right and we've
been working heavily on what we can do
to trust the hard this the hardware and
I was always undermine his arguments and
saying look but that's not true if you
look at the fact that you can't trust
that Hardware
um there's no way you can protect you
can guarantee that any software is is
yeah I I agree and and that's why I was
surprised that he wasn't uh worried
about it it seemed to run counter to his
normal
well he was not consistent I mean again
you can prove anything if you make the
wrong assumptions and I I go back to my
initial remarks uh 40 minutes ago
um
inside is on the call too well and Peter
I just want to note on that consistency
like all of us on this call are
completely consistent and totally
culturally rational
I'm consistent on a few things that I've
been involved in since the 60s
relating to trustworthy systems true and
um I haven't changed my tune very much I
was in a very awkward situation in the
electronic voting thing
when I signed onto the letter that said
there was no uh
no misgiving in the Obama election
uh I'm sorry in the uh
the Biden election
uh despite what Trump was saying uh but
I was also uh I just published the
article in the ACM about uh the
electronic computer systems have no
audit Trail and for the most part
they're not trustworthy
so I'm I'm hung in the middle but I've
been consistent on both sides
the thing saying that you can't trust
the uh the voting machines
since 1988. you're para consistent
because there are certain parts of your
framework that's consistent another part
that's consistent but again it depends
on the assumptions you're making
the standard cryptography problem is oh
we've got an absolutely 100 guaranteed
secure system
and then they put it on a Microsoft
platform where they got the secret key
is embedded into the uh operating system
as a constant
that's not very secure
so again it's a question of what
assumptions are you making
but Carl it was he was always a little
woolly about some of the assumptions and
you're trying to pin him down and you
discover your terminology was orthogonal
to his
and that made it very difficult to argue
with him
because he was assuming things that that
I wasn't
he couldn't get down to axioms
um you try we try but sometimes the
axioms were
descriptively vague
and so there's always the problem of
trying to pin down something that's in
words
which is why we go to formal methods for
example but even there you don't know
what the assumptions are that are being
made that you've just proved something
is correct
even if you have actions that describe
the hardware uh no one can tell whether
someone's changed the hardware or it
doesn't satisfy the Axiom anymore that's
right we've got we've got uh speculative
execution and and the uh the direct
memory access problems with embedded
microcontrollers that are proprietary
and undocumented made in China
you have no idea what the hell is going
on in the hardware
a lot of this discussion about him
uh being able to
prove things about things that other
people didn't think made any sense
um is is again related to the
assumptions that he was making
and you know it was wonderful to argue
with because he argued incessantly about
one thing or another
the delightful to have a discourse with
him did any has any did anyone ever
succeed in convincing him he was wrong
about something
I I had problems with that I've got I
got him to make small tweaks but I never
got him to say oh no that was wrong no I
I once I once convinced him he was he
was wrong about something and he
acknowledged my you know alternative
explanation for what he was talking
about and then he just
went on after that as if this
conversation had never happened it just
basically did not deflect him at all it
was it was it was quite funny
I I got him to admit that he was wrong
but that had more to do with personal
things like interrupting me before I was
finished
he said he wasn't doing that
well he agreed that that was not a good
thing to do oh good okay
yeah but is it you're very lucky you're
very fortunate then because that was oh
I had to train him on lots of things
it's very hard to interrupt him when he
was when he was on a rant well but
that's not really Interruption that's
what's known as enthusiastic listening
or
um as a
um uh oh for a mansplaining man's plenty
but sometimes he would before I got a
chance to explain or ask
and this is the the quintessential thing
that I would get angry about is that I
would want to ask a question and he
would he would start to answer it before
I finish the question thinking he knew
what it was going to be but he'd get it
wrong sometimes so when sometimes oh
what's his accuracy rate
oh I didn't keep track but I hated it
anyway because I gotta I want to get it
out before but anyway he admitted that
that was not a good thing to do so every
time I caught him in it he would stop
well I know that's not a speculative
execution I guess
are no petsius likes to say that he he
likes to listen with his mouth open
that's not a good thing by the way
you're not the only partner who
complained about it my wife let me have
it many times over the exact same issue
yeah and there's statistics about that
that in groups that uh men do more of
the talking and women do less of the
talking and they think they do less in
the talking and all this stuff yeah but
there's some cultures which do this
regularly overlap
New York
New York ethnics yeah Jews we're talking
at the same time and they're both not
listening to each other so that's yeah
but you know when I when I'm with my
friends and they're talking over me like
I'm talking over you right now sorry uh
they're also listening but Carl would
get an idea in his head about what I was
going to say and he wouldn't change it
unless I you know I had to beat on him
pretty hard because his idea was better
than yours
that's what he would say but sometimes
my ID was better
and he would admit it
that's really weird for a guy
well I I
dictated him I made him a feminist and
he would admit that he was by the end
well not when he was at MIT I believe
I've heard oh that's right well he had
to put up the front you know
the misogynist front
no I've I've had him back down on things
like in one lecture I think he claimed
that the an implication was not
equivalent to its contrapositive which
is like basic propositional logic and uh
I think uh he uh eventually backed down
on that when uh I and other people uh
objected
maybe he was right but uh we overruled
him well I just off the top of my head
it wouldn't be equivalent in
intuitionistic logic whatever
um I'm not sure about that I think it
might still be because you can't reduce
not not not P to p and intuition that's
true this is what it isn't you know
there you go you computer scientists
always talking about my head
let's not get into it
so Paul are you not a computer scientist
no I'm I'm I'm
no I'm I'm not sure what I am but I'm
most qualifiedly not a computer
scientist how would you identify
yourself
uh
I've been accused of being a futurist
with the past
that's interesting and I'm I'm scab
labor at Stanford in fact I've got a
student conference call in 15 minutes
but
so I shovel smoke for a living
I'm a parasite living off the
intelligence of people like you all and
Carl
are you worried about Chachi PT Paul I
love it I you know come on I said to my
students who the first day of the
quarter I said please if you want to use
chat GPT to do your papers do so just
let me know uh listed as co-author and
and you know my my working hypothesis I
I know it's wrong but you know I'm old
enough to remember when everybody had
their knickers in a knot over uh the
arrival of you know
um mathematical calculators in high
school and civilization didn't end with
that
um so I figure you know
at least mathematical calculators were
generally correct
yeah and they didn't have a political
bias yeah my son can't still can't do
arithmetic without one and you needed to
use a reverse polish in order to use
them for a few years oh hey I mean
listen guys
that's I use reverse polish
every day wow
oh well I still have mine as well I uh
but I really use mine and I you know for
that if I'm not doing heavy tasks it's
the 12C so
is that so no I'm not a computer
scientist but but I'm a nerd uh it's a
uh this this one's the uh 41 CV uh and
then I have a CX I I buy them on eBay
just to have a couple of round in case
one breaks but yeah I use the web-based
version for of them oh that's depraved
yeah isn't it
what do they cost about 10 bucks
uh it sort of depends and I've got a
full full set of all the IL peripherals
that I never use so if anybody is dying
to have an IL printer and and tape
storage give me a call hey I love that
so much I was uh a sophomore in college
and I spent 300 that was you know like
1966 that was real money
I got news for you that was not 1966. I
think the 41 came out in I want to say
73 or 75 35. oh yeah well I've got a 35
and 67 and a bunch of others and and I'm
at that point where I gotta get this
crap out of my life so if anybody wants
a well so Paul should we invest in
futures
foreign
I would have loved to talk to Carl about
is uh you know thanks to the recent
crypto meltdown it's being exposed that
they're uh I I think I heard the term
future Bros and that everybody's now
slamming the idea of long-term
responsibility because twits like Peter
Thiel and uh and Nick Bostrom are giving
it a bad name and and stuff so
maybe don't invest in futures
I have a question for did Carl have some
interaction with the philosophy
community
uh
we started csli and then shortly after
that or I don't know Carl would come
over and go to office office to talk to
people
and um
he and I really got along I think
because I was about the only one over
there
that that would listen to him when he
started saying girdle was wrong
it really didn't go over well with the
logicians and the philosophers but
I don't know it seemed something I was
willing to think about
and I think that's mostly what we had in
common we we met
weekly for a couple years usually at
Starbucks
and well I I think our political opinion
going back to the 60s where we both
anti-war were
pretty similar and um
you know just I was willing I kind of
just think
philosophy went off the rails
a long time ago but I don't
I don't know which rails it went off of
so uh uh girl girl was wrong well I mean
could be
um
and he was attracted to my stuff
not because he read it understood it and
thought it was right because it
disagreed with people he thought should
probably be disagreed with
I think the comparable argument was that
was wrong
the comparable argument was that Newton
was wrong yeah well well for the wrong
reasons I mean regardless and wrong but
again it goes back to the assumptions
that he was making
yeah but you know Newton
may have decided that uh uh weight
wasn't basic but at least he
took on the project of explaining what
it was yeah as opposed to Modern
scientists who think time is unreal but
they don't and never mind don't give up
on it yeah okay but Carl and I really
enjoyed each other's company without my
understanding his Deep Thoughts but not
rejecting out of hand because they
agreed with other established Heroes
that's okay many of us feel the same way
about you yes he uh he would play along
with my thoughts because I was
disagreeing with a lot of people without
I think ever I remember one time we
really got to the bottom of things and
he said well
I figured you didn't think there was any
such thing as a thing or something like
that and at that point I had to punt
because
but no I I don't know of anyone else in
the philosophy Department
or even among the logistics that I knew
that um
he spent a lot of time with but he and I
spent a lot of time together I really
miss him
uh and that doesn't surprise me but
there is there is some some deep sense
in which he was a philosopher in the in
the in the informal sense of the term
right people on the street would if they
talk to this guy I mean he was doing
deep philosophical things yes I I think
that's right and I think if I got to
know him uh
uh when when he was younger and I was
younger
uh and we'd each lived about another
hundred years we we really might have
come up with something
but um
even even David Israel who's uh
most of you guys probably know who's
pretty um
pretty open-minded uh he I couldn't
convince him to join me and talk to
talk to talk to him so I don't know
but he goes down in my book as one of
the most interesting people I knew
and and he used to hang out around a lot
at Hoover Tower
and it gave me the impression that he
was getting all kinds of inside
information about China and stuff from
them
I wouldn't say I believed him but I
didn't really disbelieve him nobody at
Hoover has any clue about China but yeah
well there is there is that
I apologize I gotta sign off and do a
student call I'm thrilled this is
recorded and Dennis just uh a modest
suggestion this is a group that should
get together more than on an occasion
like this
just I've heard some wonderful things in
life as a no-bit
we're we're
scheduled to have several of these over
the year because uh of other uh uh sad
events and uh we'll see everybody have
the opportunity to come in and chat
about this sort of thing because these
people that we're losing are people that
touched all of our lives
well it's not just do it when people are
disappearing yeah
are you still on
yeah
I wanted to go back to the issue that
everything is an actor
and you and I have been involved with
other people on capability based
architectures for years
um he would always look at on everything
as if it had been solved long ago in in
the actorspace
uh when there were details of
implementation that were certainly not
raised by his model
yeah um there's a guy Dale Schumacher
that I referred you to at one point who
has a a Blog and it's titled actors all
the way down and he does it all the way
down to the hardware so um we can talk
offline yeah separately okay
uh and I spent uh a dozen years or more
um implementing actors for Carl I worked
for him at uh I was a research scientist
at the mitai lab so uh I can address any
questions you have
about that Peter yeah okay
and Dale worked with Carl for a while
trying to implement his new language
actor script but never could get a clean
enough definition to finish the
implementation
yeah but I implemented um actors on list
machines by ethernet so we had a fully
distributed actor implementation and
everything was an actor right so we were
able to you know I was I think actors
are still the absolute best way of
thinking about parallel and distributed
computation I I actually had to reinvent
them to get my work done yeah
so you know I think it's the trends in
in in parallel Computing and
distributive Computing I think are now
kind of vindicating a lot of what uh
what Carl had to say about those those
ideas and plus they have very
interesting security properties in
addition to the computational properties
has anyone written up the history of
that or you know a retrospective uh
analysis of of the early Act of work and
how and its implications for for the
future
uh well I I no I mean I could write
something of a retrospective the I did
write um for the implementation that I
did
um I did write a kind of pretty
comprehensive uh
uh uh paper about it that wound up in a
book about object-oriented programming
um I there were uh two papers that I
then that that uh uh so I could send you
that or uh well I was just more
interested in in making sure that that
Carl's ideas
get get out there and and I mean this is
the kind of thing that should appear in
cacko right as a review article of on
his contribute on the on the actor
framework and and how it it I don't
understand it myself very well but it
sounds like it has potential solutions
to a lot of outstanding issues yep yep I
mean I think about it for anybody else
who would want to collaborate on such a
thing I'd be willing to think about that
but yes I think and and you know some of
his ideas did make it out into
contemporary
um parallel systems or you know his
students fanned out and went to work for
Microsoft and other companies and um
some of those ideas did make it into
modern uh things and then there's
um one of you know I worked with Carl uh
we published in 1983 a paper on Wheel
the first real-time garbage collection
algorithm and that is really virtually
on every literally on every computer in
the world
in some form or another you know in the
operating system in one of the
programming languages so Carl has had
enormous influence and I think as
parallel and distributed computing
become more popular that will continue
to happen but I I found Carl's early
paper 73 paper on actors I found it
incomprehensible at the very least it's
a very hard slog so a better written
explanation would would be of great yeah
so from the you know for the there's
gulaga's book
you know that's one source
um but again I'd be happy to share uh
with the I'll put a link in the chat
Carl Carl tried to explain to me the
differences between his thinking and
Google's August thinking and uh when I
read go auger's book I could see there
there was a difference there so I'd like
to get a coherent explanation of Carl's
thinking on on actors I'd also be
interested in how it changed over the
over the years from 73 on yeah
um now of course yeah go ahead
uh now of course you know my in my
writing it was the best understanding
that I had but of course you know there
might have been differences between Carl
and me or between me and you know the
Two of Us in gulaga uh but I think that
the idea I think and let me just say a
word about this bit about you know
everything being an actor I mean for
years and years people thought oh that's
ridiculous you mean to tell me that two
is an actor when it's just a couple of
bits you know but I think that's a very
very profound idea and the only two
formalisms that really have gotten that
down correctly that I know of are actors
and small talk and outside of that you
know all the objects in Python and C
plus plus and all the other languages
that have tried to have object-oriented
programming so-called they don't have
that they just add some notion of
objects onto
uh more uh conventional
representations and the problem with
that is that you can have things like
Futures you know future depends on being
able to have total transparency between
an object that's computed in parallel
and an object that's computed in in
serial and object computed remotely and
an object computed locally the big thing
about having everything be an actor is
that that made the issues of parallel
and distributed computing transparent
and I think that was really profound
uh what what about Quantum Computing is
that uh an accurate problem
uh that's a good question I don't know
enough personally about Quantum
Computing to be able to say whether how
it would fit in that category but uh you
know if I knew more about Quantum
Computing and I was also worried about
your earlier comment where you said you
the actors can go down to the ion level
uh it seems to me you can't really model
the hardware well in the implementation
I had the idea of what was called and I
explained this in the paper called a
rock bottom actor which is an actor that
is represented by whatever the machine
representation is so if it's the number
two then yeah it is just a couple of
bits but the idea of having the The
Interpreter checks for Rock Bottom
actors at each uh you know part of The
Interpreter cycle so this and if you do
a you know and it knows where all the
the the scripts for The Rock Bottom
actors are so so
you can Sim so it essentially means that
in those cases you can simulate having a
full actor when in fact you know the
machine just represents it quickly so
that's the the the the bottom me out of
of the formalism and that was it took
some while to work out that out make it
work in all the cases but I did make it
work and it made a huge difference I
think in the system are there were there
versions of the active framework where
you could have different levels of
abstraction so you could treat something
that was not truly primitive treat it as
primitive
for purposes of you know for now and
then later if you needed to to expand it
yeah I'm not you know I'm not sure I
mean we had mechanisms and you know you
could unpack different layers of the
implementation so you had to go a little
bit below what we would call the user
level uh or the pro developer level of
for something like that you know but
um but it was possible in you know in
our case the underlying implementation
uh what language was lisp so
you know we inherited kind of the
objectness of lisp bear
okay I think we're running out of time
yeah I think that's true
well I just like to say it's great
seeing some of you who I haven't seen
literally in decades like so it's great
catching up with you it's uh too bad it
has to be on such a sad occasion
foreign
in many ways
um and he looked at things almost
everything differently from everybody
else
and therein lies some of the discussions
that we've been having where there were
potential disagreements that may or may
not have been disagreements we don't
know really
you couldn't pin him down enough to
figure out what what was really going on
yeah I just want to know for uh I just
put in the um I just put in the chat my
paper for those who are interested
I want to thank you for inviting me give
me a little bit perspective on this guy
I became great friends of us without
ever knowing what the f he was talking
about uh he he did give me a tremendous
amount of reprints
so to keep our conversations going
search for two or three sentences that I
understood and that was usually enough
to get started the next time and I want
to apologize for not asking you if it's
okay to smoke but I should have done
that
that comment reminds me of something you
once said to me probably 40 years ago
if you're assigned to comment on a
long paper and you don't understand
anything past page three it's a good
idea to find serious problems on page
one
[Laughter]
but I'm a great teacher for people like
me that don't really understand all that
much of what they read yeah but bye bye
thanks a lot thank you see you again and
and some others okay
okay I want to say one more thing though
before you where everybody goes
um the um
uh the source of all uh
active work that Carl's doing is he was
he was a prolific writer and everything
came in versions so you get the 121st or
122nd grade of a particular paper he
also used the archive services like our
gravex and uh Hal very heavily and you
know to this day there are copies of his
earlier papers in various forms in the
archives if you're looking to see what
work he has been doing or had been doing
that's a good place to start
anyhow thank you all for coming